today on our show Mark Millar goes to
Netflix and Disney runs away from
Netflix man it's all Netflix Rochelle
nut flicks and chill hey I'm fat man I'm
Batman
[Music]
we just come in to Batman I'm Batman
Kevin Smith I'm mark barnard uh Netflix
you know what you love it can't live
without it man it is it's the new
cocaine pretty much it's the teat from
which we all suckle everybody's got to
have it everybody wants it mmm if you
get hooked baby it's nobody else's fault
so don't do it net minute minute net and
that flex didn't end in a minute
Wow thank you old-school serious hi baby
Netflix congratulations to Mark Millar
man I'm an early Millar booster I love I
fell in love with him when he took over
swampthing [ __ ] dogs ago when 25 26
27 years ago at this point god that's
crazy
Mark Millar who has been a diligent
[ __ ] worker and creator in the field
of comics and given us comics that have
given us the movies kick-ass wanted I
mean
Kingsman King's Men and also he's a good
service old man Logan which gave us
Logan Logan evil at the first Civil War
which gave a Civil War we did oh yeah a
Civil War not good not five-figure
Siegrist that's right Marc noir has been
doing it and doing it well as we say for
damn near 30 years I think in comics 25
at least or something like that
wonderful storyteller never hearing a
bad [ __ ] about a wonderful Scotsman
never like you know some scandal
involving or anything like that just
creates loves to create men they're good
at it
Netflix bought Millar world yet their
first ever acquisition and it was a
comic book guy yeah somehow I feel
validated but I had done to do it it but
I'm like right on good for you the comic
book guy number one number two I like
that guy yes what is it so they acquired
Millar
Rome is he was that's his label right
that's a sort of publishing company
through which he publishes all of the
books he does to image including
Kingsman and Jupiter's journey and
Empress and they bought it all I got
something of something killing nine
titles on the middle world that means
they could take his library and turn
into a bunch of [ __ ] right because
that's we're in the world where we take
a library and turn into a bunch of [ __ ]
and they'll give them a logo and stuff
like that but not that's Canada's
somebody I saw one of their statements
there it is
here's a a statement OOP well we got an
official statement from Netflix 799 that
was nice its creator a inventor of some
of the most memorable stories and
characters in recent history ranging
from Marvel's The Avengers to Millar
world's kick-ass Kingsman wanted and
reborn franchises mark is as close as
you can get to a modern-day Stanley said
Netflix Ted sir and OHS Wow that's those
are high praise and you know with some
may bristle at first but you could think
about it not wrong yeah not wrong he's
great I mean grant didn't create as many
[ __ ] characters of Stan but he's a
modern-day staying nobody has yeah
nobody has never will man that's like
[ __ ] Gretzky's record nobody's
touching that you know the rules the
game changed in such a way that nobody
ever would touch it so this is fantastic
great for Mark Boal arm and like
couldn't happen to a nicer guy
and yay comic books yeah and great for
you guys because you're going to get to
see a lot more comic book entertainment
transformed into live action or
animation is the same old same old like
it's my Marvel and DC's you're gonna get
these characters yeah well now this deal
doesn't include kick-ass or kings men or
I wanted or reborn I don't think but
it's everything else that he publishes
and they're gonna keep making [ __ ] it's
not as if they're going to suddenly stop
making comic books like they wrote
they're now a publishing company under
the umbrella of Netflix man oh man what
a great day
the Mark Millar's oh hell yeah he's
rolling in it and also for us because we
get to see it because they're not gonna
let just be comic books be creative like
Mark malarkey [ __ ] head down and be
creative was that money or was that
tickling tiny balls
ticklin the tiny balls give the American
consumer that's what Mark Millar's been
doing for decades and now he's been
rewarded with a fluke good on unit what
came out wasn't sludge of humanity it
was Luke all money came out of that
green gold good for mark so that's what
happened in there at Netflix now in
massive Netflix news we buried the lede
because I like Mark noir so he goes
first yes but let's be honest the big
[ __ ] story this week that never one
should have seen coming but in the world
we live in
yeah well oh my gosh I can't believe it
I do the player this guy has fallen
Netflix hmm they're about to lose all
their Disney product not quite all I
know okay I know
uh yeah me more a lot of the movies a
lot of that here Yuto right they are not
going to lose a Marvel they're not going
to lose Star Wars but they are going to
lose all of the Disney animated pictures
they lose all of the Pixar pictures we
mean so Star Wars movies are still going
to be on this link to Star Wars and
Marvel and the Marvel movies and then
why wouldn't this [ __ ] Mick well the
Marvel TV shows makes sense to keep it
meta decks but why would they if I'm the
Disney app I'm like you know it's gonna
drive people they're not just mallanna
and [ __ ] like that but like Avengers I
mean I think they're they're honestly
happening on there are two counting on
parents depending on parents you can no
longer buy the ship it's in the Disney
Vault so they want to watch Emperor's
New Groove they want to watch Moana they
want to watch Lion King and Little
Mermaid and Pocahontas and the Hunchback
of Notre Dame which nobody wants to
watch but if you wanted to you could why
we know why [ __ ] oh my god it makes
no sense for them to put all you know
what Disney has integrity no that's not
it you know it doesn't have a long
content dick yeah and I don't mean long
contented because it sleeps well I mean
a long content dick they've been making
[ __ ] for Oh ever yeah since back when
[ __ ] was black and white think you've
run a whole channel just Mickey Mouse
Club episodes and alone so we're going
to create this app where they're like
hey man you like Disney guess where you
go the Disney app just like right now
you like Disney go to the Disney Store
you like Disney go
world so why should they send you over
to Netflix their contract runs out in
2018 or so my god yeah the end of 2018
so they're like yuck
and they're going to create their own
version of Netflix which is an all
Disney Netflix called Disney something
Disney get unlimited probably on a telex
I guess that's that's what these or the
Magic Kingdom that's what I'm rollin
thank you call me one percent yeah just
one just a taste I mean I love
description I'm of two minds you know I
always like a thing that allows you to
have access to a bunch of stuff you
wouldn't ordinarily have access to so if
you get to go back and watch the sword
in the stone and the great adventures
and the Great Mouse Detective and all of
that [ __ ] I just want to watch the Apple
Dumpling gang I just want to watch one
of our dinosaurs is missing I just want
to watch the computer wore tennis shoes
I just want to watch the World's
Strongest Man I want to watch all the
Disney movies of my childhood like watch
now Netflix you fat dick I'm like wow I
will before they leave but then I'll get
this Disney app because they're worth it
I'll give them my $7.99 but that gets to
be the problem is that if everybody has
their own dedicated app if everybody if
CBS has an app and the SPO has an app
and FX has an app and Disney hasn't
happened here
Hulu has an app and Amazon has an a
penis suddenly you begin adding up at $8
a month yes all apps are created equal
and they equally cost the same amount of
money yes and then you're paying more
for than you did for cable pretty much
but you get it on your phone you get on
your phone but here's the name we were
talking about little beforehand so this
is entirely fresh to either was but you
lose the capacity to browse for things
you lose that capacity to discover a
[ __ ] for sorry
I'm kidding good yeah like when when I
was a child when he was a child you
could go to a Blockbuster Video link
it's a single 'm you could go to a Tower
Records and you could look at stacks you
could hey the cover that [ __ ] looks fun
maybe I'll pick it up hey the guy at the
clerk said this was a good idea maybe I
should rent this like you could discover
[ __ ] at random you can flip channels and
just oh [ __ ] it on 4 October is on I
never saw it maybe I'll watch it now now
with every app that comes out you have
to become a targeted consumer you have
to know what you want and know where to
go get it and that eliminates the idea
of random discovery of oh [ __ ] I was
flipping down Netflix the massive queue
of Netflix and hey there's a thing that
just look
kind of interesting I'll watch it
because if here if everything becomes
removed then you lose the chance to just
stumble onto awesome my point was Disney
has always separated themselves from
everybody else
here's a whole world full of [ __ ] here's
a whole store full of [ __ ] and there are
some people that are just Disney I'm
going to talk about anything else on
Netflix so I understand what you're
saying but like you probably those cats
think we're never going off the kids
page anyway you know and they were never
gonna flick around be like yo Gosar's
what's today and but it was never about
disney per se but it's this race towards
a dedicated app it's the race that
everybody has ly it is it's shocking
honestly they haven't done it already
yeah but Disney has always been like not
in the making of movies Pixar well they
acquired Pixar but like technologically
speaking do you remember like they got
into the internet like later and then
they bought the go network so for every
got all their dresses were ABC go comm
done go [ __ ] long and stuff but they
kind of got into that a little bit like
a hair late and it feels like they're
creating their own app a hair late as
well
that being said everybody's head in this
direction I read that CW is going to do
one or Warner but like I think that's
where titans is going to live on the CW
dedicated app that's where the
restructure discovery will live after
the Principia doesn't forget CBS all
access like everybody's trying to give
you the one thing you're tuning in for
and then make you pet pay eight dollars
a month to try to Game of Thrones they
need their lawn Game of Thrones on their
network that makes you go [ __ ] I gotta
give them my money yeah and then they
got you and then they got you and
they're hoping that you won't notice
every month when you automatically pay
auto get it from your account like hey
didn't I used to have a hundred dollars
this month every month auto-debit is a
German filmmaker that we both admire
quite a bit yes this picture died
plumbed in one of my favorites and of
course Oh scheisse the comedy that can't
be beat auto-debit snitching grubens so
let's talk about what happens to Netflix
in the wake of this threat are they okay
will they crumble they're probably going
to be fine
because I mean he built up enough loyal
following with their original program
average Markel one point where they were
like by 2020 we want to be 75% original
programming you know they don't want to
have to rely on a package of somebody
else's movies now granted that's always
cheaper like it's cheaper or licensed
movies than it is to create your own
content but you know they seem to have a
buck or two they do however there was
that article that was released a couple
weeks back and they were like now
they're running big debt yeah I mean in
you know a company of that size will
always carry debt like that's just the
way you run a corporation like you're
not actually making quote/unquote profit
you're just having access to the capital
so that you can continue to deficit
financing whatever that's Forbes
[ __ ] but okay I feel like they need
one or two more giant [ __ ] shows yeah
like stranger things was there sort of
quantum leap into oh my god everybody's
talking about Netflix had a big bad way
yeah but weren't they doing that with
house of cards I'm looking part of that
discussion myself but stranger things
I'm more inclined to be part of the
mission but that house of cards brawn
and the orange is the new black like
they were able to build audiences that
were buzzing like this shows their
videos most of their original not
everything like definitely keeps people
talking stranger things though whole new
level yeah I mean it's it's bananas and
like that to show that yes they've got
any nominations before but stranger
things has the most this year and it's
traditionally the kind of genre it
doesn't get love from the MU absolutely
right about they went to town on it well
observed I mean I feel like town go to
town on I feel like you know how certain
are James house the cars the noise of
the new black is a bit like they're the
wire yeah it is like an incredible show
that gets a lot of love from critics and
and absolutely does some service for
them in terms of putting them in the
face of the planet but it's not the
Sopranos yet they're not imperative
drones yet and stranger things feels
like it's their first actual aroni it
goes a little clowny so they need like
one or two more of those and then well
then that's like the Marvel Netflix
shows they're doing really well for them
all yeah they've watched a nice niche
there I don't understand though if I was
Disney I do like we're taking it all
lock stock and barrel guess what you
want to wash your [ __ ]
Marvel shows you watchin on to Disney I
mean I think those are Co Productions
which is the only reason my Netflix know
has it tooks in it but and because it's
a [ __ ] shared universe what a
level-headed guy he is me I'm like burn
at all dracarys
like well I think they have some money
give it all that desi yeah it'll be fine
for Disney will be fine for you if you
want the stuff you know exactly where to
get it nothing is going away do you
think the price point starts dropping
once you get more apps out there I don't
know can you still sustain that ask or
do you stuck on like well we do ours for
$5.99 I mean I'm not sure honestly that
price for a thing has ever done down
especially for a consumer product like
I've never suddenly no should I went to
the movies it was cheaper than it was
last year because the movies aren't as
good if you go during a matinee
well yeah if you want Monday so if I
sleep all day if you made a mom go to
like mommy movie Mondays [ __ ] yes
look no Fupa Lulu in a world of many app
channels OTT channels they gone over the
top of channels babel vision comm is one
two hey pre plug we're in lose done
excellent a lot more content on their
psyche really dude the one show it's
going to open up a story about like we
acquired Mark Millar would our app is
not nearly as big yeah well give it time
there's Netflix right now its landing on
the roof so yeah drone yeah they're like
we're delivering a signal for you to
watch the show that's how much we care
personally on by a helicopter
um Netflix folks on a tear honest air
and losing some [ __ ] Disney folks so
wait let's just say it's going to be a
Disney app yes and there's gonna be an
ESPN oh yeah people of like sporting
events the sport balls I'm most scared
by that stuff but yes they will have
their own app channel the ESPN app
channel which people have been crying
about for a long time like in a world of
like these dedicated packages like NHL
has center ice we've won every game for
one why can't yes BN haven't happened
now they will I mean I would watch it if
only for this
about 30 s you watch those documentaries
some of them not all but yes I mean
they're rather well done some of them
vector into my areas of interest but I'm
the Summum like I don't care about this
board but some like there when the Venn
diagram of things that interest me in
ball somewhere else could go interesting
so two half channels coming away from
Disney and one app channel still
standing strong never like Disney has
technically we will have three op
platforms the Disney app whatever it's
going to be called the SPN applets can
be called and they saw the stake in Hulu
as well oh that's right which is whether
if they're there other programs are
going to be they're not pulling those
either so interesting any everything
will be everywhere and then nothing will
be nowhere I don't know what that means
you can't [ __ ] get more profound than
that [ __ ] that's why you tune into a fat
man on Batman here mark barnard and wax
[ __ ] smarten intelligently making
[ __ ] up on the regular things good yeah
I said I can't say anything else more
about Netflix except I'm gonna go watch
that [ __ ] right now
hey I'm gonna go watch all the Disney
movies before they go away there it is
probably not Batman I've been Kevin
Smith I've been marked with a tune in
next time saying fact time same fat
chance podcast.com youtube.com slash
Kevin Smith all that was smooth issues
ya know I like that I like the robot
thank you
[Music]
you